選べられる それにプラスあの無印の八
無印の八はどうしてもついてくれますから
それでこちら二番目でいいことをしたならば
ここから七つの中で選べなくちゃいけないんですね
一番目はダメと  それってあの
さっき正しく言ったみたいに
その結果として死ぬ瞬間にそれほど変化ってことですか？私が
そこが私は問題視してるんですけど
置いときたいんですけど
今の  変化しなければ同じものとして
じゃあ 다시はまた同じ心っていうふうになってしまうから
それはちょっと置いておきたいんですけど
もうちょっと先で  今現在のことで理解してないと
その先を混ぜちゃったら話がこんがらがっちゃう
いや こんがらがっちゃう
それ  生まれ変わった時に変わるでしょ
変わるでしょ？変わらなきゃおかしいよ
名前は違うけど どれか一つに
変わるんですよね  とプラス無印
いや 当然のことだから
そういう点でしょって言ってるんです
それはできればもうちょっと後で勉強したいですね
僕はさっきの先生の あの
死んで生まれ変わるなんてもういいです
今は もっと後 アビダンマの後に読めればいいです
それまで我慢します  さっきほら
瞬間に変わる心があって
死ぬ時って言ったよね
それはいいです 後で置いときます
もうちょっと  本当にね
今 今解決したいと思わないです
言ってもあったらあって
で それっていわゆるこれは階層性みたいになってて
一番は一番から八番までの中
二番は二番から だけど下位のものは上のものにはいかないと
そういう解釈でいいんですよね
そうですね ですから   あとはプラス精進とか
違うの 千円持ってる人にとっては
買い物は千円の買い物もできるし
百円の買い物もできるし
でも千円持ってる人には千五百円の買い物はできない
だから一旦買い物をしちゃったらもう終わりでしょ
わかります  え？ わかります
問題はでもだから変化の
それは言った先生の言葉を借ります
生まれてから死ぬまで同じだ
その因縁が育ったら 人間として生まれた能力はそういうものとしての変化はそれはないというふうに解釈するんですけど
ただ そこから じゃあ死ぬ時に次のまた一から八までのその新たに選ぶということも
ものが少しおかしい  選ぶっていうことが使えちゃうからおかしいんです
何べん言ったってもう
選ばない 選べない  選べないんだ
自動的に  選べないか その覚悟で極楽行くのは当たり前です
当たり前 そう変化ができるのであれば
まず根本はできます であれば
今のところでは  だからあれは今世で受ける結果
先ほど言ったことでしょう
結果として  それは一生の心
基本はベースは変わらないです
で 今世でいろんな悪いことしてちゃうでしょ
そしたら次の結果を待つ時の時に並ぶだけなんで
いろんな意味になってるんですよね
その答えの中に入ってるから
だから問題はこの言葉に引っかかる
同じと言った途端 いきなり頭の中であるのは一本一つの
一本の棒のように同じものだと
これおかしいでしょうに
例えばこの何かミルクコーヒーでしょ
もう一本買ってきてください
同じでしょ だからといって全く同じというわけじゃないでしょうに
もう一本買ってきたら
それはもう一本だけど
ミルクコーヒー同じものなんですよ
そういう同じということなんです
それということなんです
私は生まれた心と死ぬ心は同じですよと言ったのは
もうこういうミルクコーヒーと同じことなんです
人間で生まれた人間と別だと
そういうような解釈でいいですか
心は瞬間瞬間 僕はこれで言っている言葉だけど
言いたくないんですけど
そういう意味でもあり得るんですか？そういう能力は
だからとにかくこの言葉の問題は
解決 自分で解決してケースしないと私にはどうすることもできないんですよ
言葉の問題っていうのは
それは自分で何とかしないと
言葉は実体論と取っちゃうと
もうもう今日は語れませんよ
言葉はあくまでもラベルであって
ラベル貼っちゃうんだから
まあちょっと私も疲れちゃったら
そこら辺適当に何とかラベル貼っちゃうだけで
私がどうしても引っかかってるのはね
生まれから死ぬまで同じ
あの 主義は同じだって言いましたでしょ
じゃあ死んだ瞬間もうまた再スタートしてしまうんじゃないかというね
とこに引っかかったんです
ここに引っかかったのね
変化するなら今こんな変化できるんじゃないかということだけど
レベル的にね 人間から動物へ返って
その次のカルマはまた違うんだというのあれば
うん まあ私はあの 死ぬ
そこは後で触れますけどね
あの 死ぬ心は生まれる心とは全く質的には同じなんですね
心は瞬間瞬間死ぬ 新しい心が生まれる
でも前死んだ心と今の心は同じ
質的に同じということだけのことで
だから常に我々は私に戻るでしょ
我に戻る それは生まれた心なんです
だからなかなか成長ないんですね
なかなか なぜならば 何か一仕事しても
一回修行したっても 次のまた我に戻ってまたリスタートでしょ
だからもう成長はそこそこの成長なんですね
だからいつでも我に戻っちゃうということで
その心なんです  そういうふうに生かすということですね
だからといって全く同じ心ではないんです
死ぬ瞬間 死ぬ瞬間でも我に戻る
そこで死ぬ でもカルマの心はもっと先にあるんです
死ぬ心で生まれないんです
それは終わったんだから
決勝心というのはもっと後
もっと前の心から出てくるんです
いわゆる死ぬ前のことで
準備で決まっちゃうんです
まあまあ それで説明しますけど
例えば人が死ぬ瞬間でいろいろ頭の中で考え方出てきて
まあ過去の人生やらいろんなものは頭に
この 何といいますか もう一つ
何画面ですか 全部 FLASH BACK みたいにチャッと出てきたりはするし
体とか心が自由になっちゃいますから
そこでもう何かに決めちゃうんです
どうしようもなく気に入っちゃうんですね
気に入った瞬間でもう我に戻っちゃう
戻った瞬間もう死んでるんです
そこで次の決勝 今あの決めたことの心と同じ心でつなげていっちゃうんです
それだけ で そこら辺まあ
アビダルマ後でそういう心の繋がりみたいなのを説明しますからね
まあどこまで とにかくそういう意熟心がありまして
意熟心というのは人間は決勝する
あと 5 分ぐらいで終わります 4
時までですか  4時半  であの意熟心はあの
あまりに色々出てきますね
カルマの結果で そこで私はこの見ること
聞くこと 味わうことが
我々の過去のカルマの結果と言ったんですね
ですから 私たちは幸福なところに生まれたならば
大体見ること いいものばっかり見たり
食べるもの 美味しいものを食べたりはするんですね
当たり前のことで それはもういいカルマしたんだから
いいところで生まれる
そこで見るものは綺麗なものは見る
綺麗な音は聞く で ちょっとカルマのエネルギーは弱い人は貧しい家庭で生まれるかもしれない
そうすると 見るものはあんまり綺麗じゃないし
着るものもあまり綺麗じゃない
色々食べるものもそんなに美味しくないということが出てくるんですね
それだけはカルマと言っちゃうと困るし
で 人間として 人として
人格も持ってますから
考え方とか そこで我々は私
私というこの思考の回転ですか
それもこの心の回転なんですね
それは眼耳鼻舌身には関係ない
眼耳鼻舌身に関係なく
心で 心として 意思として
自我意識として回転しているんですね
だから勉強できるかできないかということは
そこら辺で決める 目が鋭いんだから勉強できるということはちょっと言いにくい
そういうことで えーと
まあそれでだいたい性格っていうのは一応一応死ぬまではまあ似ていて決まっているということで
それで次の八種類は唯沙心というんですね
心は全く同じ 大心の次の八は大唯沙心八
大唯沙心というのは また喜
怒 痴 想 応 無業 信と 同じなんです
名前は この唯沙心八というのはカルマではない
結果でもない いわゆる阿羅漢ですね
心は完全に悟った人が阿羅漢の人々
阿羅漢になった聖者たちも聖者とは決して悪いことをしないでしょう
人をぶったりはしないし
貶したりもしないし 人のものを盗んだりもしないし
もう煩悩は全くないんだから
阿羅漢になった人々は毎日いいことしかしないんです
瞬間 瞬間でも嫌な気持ちは生まれてこないんだから
心はきれい そのまんまそのままだから
そうすると一般の人とは全く比べないほどなんですね
我々は笑ったっても悪
悪であろうし 何かやっちゃってももういい加減にやっちゃいますわ
そこで怒りが入っているし
あるいは無知が入っちゃう
もう罪ばっかりなんですけど
阿羅漢になったらもう全く正反対で
心は完全に綺麗だから
そうすると綺麗な心でやることは全部いいカルマになるはずなんですけど
カルマになるぐらいさえ煩悩はないんです
全部捨ててるんです 何も要りません
ですから ただ単に行いだけしただけの
結果はなし あのまあわかりやすい例を言います
仏教ではこのお布施すると徳は
徳の順番 こういうふうに決まってるんです
例えば 私は何か品物を持っている
それは人にお布施しようとする
それでお布施というか寄付をする
人にあげたら徳があるんです
それで徳の順番があるんです
私がこの持っている品物は
悪いことをして儲かったものであるならば
徳は低いんです 品物自体が
で 私が持っている品物自体
私は正しく儲かったもので
正しく仕事をしている
自分がふさわしく得たものであるならば
その徳が高い それで私はそれを性格的に大変乱れている悪い人にあげちゃうんだと
悪い人にあげたってもあげたことだから徳があるんです
悪い人にあげたんだから罪ですよってないでしょうに
たとえ人を殺した人であろうが
ご飯お腹が空いているならば
じゃあご飯食べなさいとご飯をあげたんだと
そうすると私も罪人になりますかね
なりませんだから ですから
布施を悪人にしたっても
布施は布施なんです で
そこでいい人がいるんだと
正直な心いい人が 心清らかな人にあげたら
いわゆる戒律を守ったり
殺人を起こさないでいる人にあげた方がもっと徳が高くなるんだと
もらった側の徳 そこでもらった側の場合は五戒
三帰している人にとっては三帰までしているんだから智慧があるんですね
その人にあげたらもっと徳が高い
その上 五戒まで守っているんだったら
さらに智慧があるんだから
それでさらに徳が高くなる
八戒守っている人にあげちゃったら
その人は五戒守る人より智慧がいいでしょうにと
それ十回守る人だったらもっと智慧がいいんだから
もっと徳が高くなっちゃう
それでもう在家であろうとも
出家 在家的な出家もありますからね
在家でありながら また出家的なこの梵行も終わっているならば
もっと徳が高い そこで出家している沙弥にあげたらもっと徳が高いんだと
沙弥でなくて比丘にお布施したらもっと徳が高いんだと
そこで個人の場合は普通のお坊さんにあげるよりは
預流果になった人 一来果になった人
不還果になった人 阿羅漢にあげたら
もうどんどんどんどん順番で徳が高くなっちゃうんですね
阿羅漢の中ではそれで最高で
それ一人で個人でしょ
それよりは一人に二人にあげた方がもっと徳が高くなっちゃうんだ
自分持ってる品物は三人に上げる
四人にあげると でもその場合は切りがありますけど
そこでサンガにあげたならば
もう無量に徳が高いんだと
なぜならば サンガの場合は数分からないんですね
何人いるかと でもお釈迦様は四人さえいればサンガとしてお布施をもらえるんだと
ですから あげる側には高い徳を得られるんですね
まあそこはそういう徳の順番が
ランクがあるんです それからもっとまた違うランクがあります
自分の徳 自分が心が乱れて汚い心でいるならば
怒りやら嫉妬やら高慢やら褒めてもらいたいとかいろいろ汚れている心でお布施すると
また徳がちょっと低くなっちゃうし
まああげなくちゃいけないんだ
まあどうせもうあげますよという感じでやっちゃうと
もうちょっとあれよりはもう褒めてほしい気持ちがないんだからね
どうせこの人にあげなきゃ帰れませんだからっていう見解ありますからね
その場合は徳はもっと上なんですね
上でであって やっぱりいいことをしなくちゃ
私たちは幸福だからいいことをしなくちゃいけないという見地だけでもっと上になっちゃうし
それを足す 例えば自分が回守ったり
回守ったりとかね するとどんどんどんどん徳が高くなっちゃうんですね
そこを行って じゃあ最高のところは自分が悟ってる状態でしょ
そう悟ったところでも最高の人でしょ
そうすると 悟った人が悟った人に何かあげると
徳が一番高いなんです
徳はないんです そこなんだよ
言ってるのは だから自分が回守ってお布施するとすっごい徳が高いんです
出家してお布施するともっと徳が高いんです
修行しながらお布施するともっと徳が高いので
心はもっと清らかだから
清らかになってなってなって
じゃあ最終的に阿羅漢になることは一番清らかな状態でしょ
その状態になったらもうカルマはないんです
ですから 阿羅漢がする行為にはカルマはないと
徳は高い話にはならない
だから徳の問題は悟るまでの話なんですね
輪廻転生するまでの話なんですね
ですから この阿羅漢たちが決して悪いことはしない
寝ても悪いことはしない
悪いことできるはずがないんだから
心はもう完全に清らかだから
だからって徳が高いかというと
全然徳もない 単なる行為
それは有為下品と言うわけです
それだけの説明で じゃあ今まで我々は種類の心の説明をいたしました
種類 そのには何と言いますか
カーマーチャー 欲界心というんです
カーマーチャー 欲界心
これはなんで欲界心って
カーマーチャーっていうのはこの眼耳鼻舌身の世界なんですね
ですから この欲という言葉に引かれちゃったら困るんです
欲の世界とか娑婆世界とかいろいろ日本語でありますね
そういう欲の世界っていう意味じゃなくて
眼耳鼻舌身の世界なんですね
生命と生命の次元 生命がいて
これ眼耳鼻舌身の次元で生きている生命
ですから神々は欲界なんですね
人間も欲界なんですね
動物も欲界なんですね
鬼神も欲界なんです 微生物も欲界なんです
地獄にいる鬼たちも欲界なんです
体を持って眼耳鼻舌身の世界にいると
です ですから阿羅漢の阿羅漢にこの八つの心が生まれるでしょ
阿羅漢には不善心が生まれませんだけどね
阿羅漢には普通に日常生活で生まれる心はもう決まっているんですね
この勇猛心の八 いいことをする場合は
行動する場合は で それからあの正気心一つと十八種類も生まれますから
ナチュラルに あの十八は生まれる
そうすると十八プラス八ですからね
三十六ですか 二十六 三十六じゃない
また間違うんですけど
そうですね それぐらいですね
二十六ぐらいの心が生まれる
他の心が生まれません
私たちにはもっとたくさん生まれるんですね
たくさんと言ったっても
この十二種類の不善心くっつけ加えるだけ
我々の場合はもう日常生活で不善心ばっかしですから
たまに善心ですから 心の数は少ないかもしれません
でも一番まあ一回数えていえば
あの不善心十二と十八種類の心と八種類の善心ですね
そういうのを生まれるんですね
またいじく心も生まれ
いじく心は意図してこまりませんだけどね
まあそれは で 欲界と呼ぶんですね
ですからこのいくら阿羅漢になっても人間ですから
まあ物を目で見たり聞いたりしますからね
まあそれはその時の心ですから
欲界と呼んであって 決してこのこの貪瞋痴みたいな欲望の世界という意味ではないんです
単なる生命の次元の問題です
それからそれは基本的な次元で
努力したってもしなくたっても
生命というと心があるんです
仏教で生命というのは心の働きに生命と言うんです
生まれ変わったということは
そこで心が現れたということで
別に生命がいるわけじゃないんですね
ですから 何か悪いカルマの結果
報いは受けてますよと言ったっても
何のことないんですよ
新しい心が生まれてるだけなんです
ですから ただ単に心の問題だけのことなんですね
例えば自分が痛みの心が生まれたら
痛い痛いで言うだけで
別に体が痛いわけじゃないんです
ただの物体だから 自分が痛みとして認識すると
もう悪いカルマで もう快感だと認識しちゃうといいカルマで
体の感情も全く同じことで
心が働くということは生命のことです
から 生命には基本的に心はどうしても働いてますよ
ですから このそこは欲界というんです
そのそれから心はもし育ったならば
どんどん強烈に強く育ったならば
欲界心の次元を飛んで上に行けることはできます
次回は色界心を説明します
色界心からは普通の心じゃないんです
ここで一般の生命の心の世界は終わります
じゃあ今日はこの辺で
[終礼]